listening to phil
rich women David Wain
and Kerry Wood on Ellie
if an investor isn't possible you
mentioned 401k funds would you suggest
also credit cards getting a second
mortgage how far would you go I don't
know I mean I might have invested later
to see how far I went but I you know
it's kind of within your means what can
you afford you definitely don't want to
get yourself into a hole where you just
are not going to be able to get out and
that's that's kind of the fine liming
how far will you are you able to go but
again how David was just saying and how
with my latest experience with what's up
lovely there are viable ways now to make
a film without spending too much money
and again with marks class but he'll
teach you some of that stuff in terms of
where you can save what do you have to
actually put your resources and to make
a movie look like it's supposed to look
but you're not spending as much and part
of that is networking that seems David
seems to be great at and and people in
this business you find people either who
can mentor you through certain things or
as a resource they can actually help you
out you surround yourself with
like-minded people who are hungry for
responsible people but they want to make
work and if you are able to find people
like that in the same shoes as you you
know you'll be surprised at how far
people are willing to go to help you
make your film and how much they will
contribute in terms of their talents and
their and their time to help you get
your vision across a lot of people don't
realize what you just have to ask and
sometimes you will get people who are on
board and they don't they believe in
your cause enough that they won't ask
for money they just want to help you out
because they love passionate people